hey you guys welcome back to flickers of
fear continuing on with the very very
fun giallo july and we're talking about
uh probably one of my
giallo or yellow adjacent uh films today
so let me say okay so while the giallo
genre as a whole
has a fairly rigid set of tropes that
most films that are called jello films
you know that fall within those
parameters that they adhere to you got
your masked killer with the gloves you
got your murder mystery element your
kind of like police investigation or
your amateur police investigation um you
got ultra violent killings committed
with bladed weapons and so forth
uh that isn't to say that some directors
didn't try to do something a little bit
different
within the confines of the style uh for
example introducing supernatural or
surrealistic elements
or
making the story less about solving a
series of interconnected murders as
focusing on one protagonist and maybe
one kind of determined madman that's out
to get them so one movie that does both
of these things uh with actually
smashing success at least in my opinion
is the movie we're going to be talking
about today and this is a particularly
it's very gothic and it's very
hallucinogenic
nightmare style of movie that uh has a
bunch of actors that will be familiar to
anyone that is versed in this genre at
all uh you have ed b finish george
hilton maria malfati lots and lots of
faces that you'll recognize so this
movie is called all the colors of the
dark came out in 1972 and it was an
italian spanish co-production but was
set in london now this was directed by
sergio martino who was also responsible
for
many many genre classics among them the
strange vice of mrs ward which i think
i've talked about on the show
the case of the scorpion's tail your
vice is a locked room and only i have
the key which i think i've also
discussed and torso which i may or may
not have discussed i can't really
remember so all the colors of the dark
though is essentially
a kind of groovier
less satirical
and way more surreal take on maybe
something like rosemary's baby
uh it has similar themes of black magic
uh ambiguous reality and sort of like
crushing paranoia
centering on one woman like a main
character who's never entirely sure if
she's losing her mind or if there's kind
of like a concentrated conspiracy of
nefarious individuals out to get her you
know what i mean so it's that kind of
thing so what you have at the beginning
you have the beautiful but uh very
mentally fragile female
protagonist jane played by edvige finish
who is just ridiculously beautiful and
she always plays she played a similar
kind of role in the strange vice of mrs
ward she always plays these kind of very
vulnerable like victim type characters
she's very good at it i think a lot of
it is just because
she just has that vulnerable looking
face she has those big dough eyes and
they always like frame them with like
you know the
the luscious like long fake lashes which
she also sleeps in in this movie which i
thought was like very funny so it's like
she wakes up and i'm just like wow she
has perfect makeup and fake lashes and
everything like that if i if i fell
asleep and fake lashes i'd wake up and
they'd be like stuck all over my face
like that but that never happens in the
movies you know what i mean everybody
has to look perfect when they wake up
but yeah she is
stunning so you can see why she was in a
lot of gela movies but she also plays
like a lot of those movie because she
has like a really good she's just very
good at looking like scared and
vulnerable
which she does a lot in this so jane
here has been going through some [ __ ] uh
to put it mildly
so not only was her mother murdered when
she was five years old and i'm sure
she's still processing some trauma from
that
but a year before the events of this
film
she was actually in a car accident in
which she suffered a miscarriage
now her longtime boyfriend
who is a pharmaceutical rep and also
kind of a condescending jackhole whose
name is richard
he was driving the car
and he sort of kinda maybe feels a
little bit responsible
for that whole losing the baby thing i
mean he was the one that like slammed
the car into the pole so you know he's a
little bit responsible but
despite this he's like yeah i'm sure
sorry about that it doesn't sound real
sincere he still kind of treats jane
like crap anyway he's pretty dismissive
of her concerns about what she fears
might be her crumbling sanity like her
emotional vulnerability and he seems to
like prioritize work over jane's health
like he's always like oh gotta go go
call that client oh gotta go meet a
client gotta go on this business trip
blah blah i'm working late you know
leaving her alone incessantly when she
many times when she begs him not to
because she thinks she's in danger or
she needs somebody there to talk to or
something like that so not super
supportive not a great situation there's
also kind of a conflict between her
sister barbara who seems to have her
best interests at heart who doesn't
really like richard and so they're
always kind of at loggerheads because
they're both arguing about what is best
for jane so there's always that so
there's that kind of conflict going on
in the background as well
now jane's main issue it seems is not so
much the miscarriage and the resentment
she feels toward richard about the car
crash although that is in there
it's more the fact that
ever since that happened jane has
actually been plagued with these
horrific very fellini-esque nightmares
uh basically and the movie actually
opens with one of these in which there's
like these toothless old ladies like
cackling and close-up and then there's
this very mysterious creepy looking dude
with these ice blue eyes and he's
repeatedly like stabbing women to death
in their beds i think like as you watch
the movie you find out this may or may
not
be like a recreation or at least the way
she remembered uh the night her mother
was murdered because like i said she was
only five when it happened so these
might be some like repressed memories so
these are like varied memories of the
past that are kind of bubbling up to
torment her since this more recent uh
tragedy more recent accident so
typically in true yellow wallpaper
fashion
richard
has been pretty much [ __ ] on jane's
wishes to see a psychiatrist
and he insists as i said he's a
pharmaceutical rep so he's like all you
have to do is just keep taking these
weird blue toilet tablet vitamins that
he's giving her this will flush away the
crazy you know he puts him in a cup and
it's just like makes it all blue and i'm
thinking oh so he subscribes to the tom
cruise school of psychiatry is evil and
scientology solves all the things with
vitamins and ot powers i guess he's that
kind of dude yeah he's really kind of a
[ __ ] but she's kind of stopped taking
them she thinks they're not working and
you know it's just playing with the tidy
bowl man hasn't been like working
not really doing her any damn good at
least in her perception so she finally
takes her sister barbara's advice
and she goes to see the psychiatrist
that barbara works for who is this
kindly old man named dr burton
now doc actually seems a lot more
understanding he actually like listens
to her concerns when she tells him like
she goes to see him and she's like oh my
god i saw this creepy man like in the
waiting room and he's like oh no you
didn't because i don't let my clients
like meet each other but then when he
goes out and barbara says oh yeah there
was like a creepy man like sitting in
here he actually apologizes oh i'm sorry
i owe you an apology you did see a man
out here you're not crazy you're not
imagining things and he tells her like
over and over that she's not crazy and
it seems to be like helping her out a
little bit but even though he does seem
a lot more understanding and actually
like listens to her uh her nightmares
aren't really going away
and what's worse she starts to see the
blue eyed man from her dreams stalking
her in real life or at least that's what
her perception is now fearing that she
might be going batshit insane as you
would
she finally in desperation i guess
confides in her foxy new neighbor mary
whose first suggestion
may be among her first suggestions
literally within a day of meeting her
is for jane to accompany her to a sabbat
you know a black magic ritual
uh that should clear that whole mental
illness thing right up uh with the
well-known healing power of beelzebub
just come along to the sabbath
everything will be fine uh it worked for
me mary and
and as i said jane is very desperate
nothing she's doing is working the
nightmares are getting worse and now
she's she's kind of like fearing that
her nightmares are starting to bleed
into reality because she's seeing this
man like on the train and following her
in the park and stuff like that but
nobody else seems to see him really so
she's kind of thinking she's losing her
marbles
so as i said because she's desperate she
gives this whole black magic ritual
thing about 10 seconds of thought
before essentially going yeah sounds
like a plan
uh so they end up going to this creepy
mansion
and after a very festive afternoon of
dog sacrifice dog blood drinking and
gang rape she seems right as rain again
so you know who knew
alternative therapy so yeah but not so
fast in a stunning twist
it will surprise no one turns out that
demonic cults headed by faye bearded men
wearing fabulous gold press-on nails may
not actually be conducive to one's
overall mental well-being who'da thought
it not me that's for sure so from here
on out the movie kind of takes on i mean
even more than previously sort of like
the aspect of a fever dream as we're not
really sure who we can trust and what's
really going on like what's real and
what's just like a dream or a
hallucination like this blue eyed psycho
dude seems to be popping up around every
corner like lurking outside her
apartment building like following her
around you know just kind of like
stalking her pretty much constantly but
is he real or is he imaginary is she
just like remembering him because like i
said he does turn up in her dreams so
you're led to believe maybe this was the
guy that killed her mom and she's like
remembering what he looks like so now
she's just like manifesting him and
she's like imagining it all
another thing is
you know is everybody jane knows like
conspiring with this satanic cult
to kind of like push her off a rocker or
kill her or do some like have some other
like nefarious purpose you know and it's
just kind of like it's one of those
things where that's kind of where the
giallo aspect comes in because
everyone's a suspect everyone is kind of
like shifty everybody does stuff that's
sort of like suspicious so you're not
really sure like who's in on it and
who's not um there's a couple of like
weird scenes where
you know what i mean there's scenes
where like richard is kind of like
looking at mary like before jane even
meets mary like he's looking at her
through the window like hey see you hey
i see you like there's something going
on there there's like some weird [ __ ]
going on between him and the sister like
are they maybe sleeping together i guess
they're not but it kind of like they're
kind of suggesting maybe there's
something going on there it's just
really weird like the way they set up
all these things there's this one
[ __ ] this is one great scene where
this is like so weird and like so
ridiculous but this kind of like lens
the whole thing this sort of like
surrealistically dreamlike kind of thing
there's one point where
you know jane is like freaking out so
much that like this blue eyed guy is
like following her that she goes to doc
burton and he's like tell you what i'll
take you out to my country house because
i have like a couple like housekeepers
like a married couple that take care of
the property and they'll like take care
of you like while i'm working it's like
so you won't be alone and you'll be safe
because no one knows you're out here so
he takes her out there but like then she
wakes up the next morning and the the
caretakers like this elderly couple
they look like they're sitting at the
breakfast table like with the paper and
everything like that but they're dead
and i was like
would a murderer really go to all the
trouble just like murdering these two
old stirs and then like meticulously
like propping them up like with toast
and orange juice and everything so it
looked in the newspaper so it looked
like they were still alive just to like
[ __ ] with her but so you know what i
mean so there's that kind of like thing
like huh is that really happening so
there's that so the surrealistic touches
from this point are kind of like coming
hard and fast and if you're watching it
you'll sort of be left confused
and kind of like on edge until the very
until everything like sorts itself out
so while there are murders in the film
the plot isn't really a classic giallo
murder mystery per se
as we pretty much know that the scary
blue-eyed guy is the main villain and
you know the guy that heads the cult
like to a lesser extent
the suspense in this one is kind of
generated
more from the fact that the murders that
do occur you're not entirely sure if
they really happened or if they happened
the way that jane perceived them to
happen you know they might have been
hallucinations or it might have just
been some others like somebody might
have dosed her there's that kind of
thing going on too and we're also kind
of drawn into the question of the extent
to which the people in jane's life like
in her immediate circle like richard her
sister barbara dr burton her neighbor
mary the the woman that takes her to the
sabbath you know how much and to what
extent are they involved in this
supposed plot by this satanic cult we're
led to presume uh to harm her or
whatever their agenda is what connection
is there to the murder of her mother
many years ago because you know that
there's probably is one so that's kind
of like where the suspense and the
tension of this one comes from not so
much from
one murderer going around like picking
off a bunch of people but
just who's involved in this conspiracy
is there a conspiracy is she just going
crazy that whole kind of thing so as i
mentioned this is actually one of my
favorite i'm not sure this might be
actually my favorite sergio martino film
i'm not um entirely sure uh i really
really dig it a lot
i just there's something about the whole
like gloomy gothic vibe of it that
really resonates with me i guess it's
like it has like this kind of weird like
early 70s like psychedelic weirdness to
it it's very very ambiguous and i really
like ambiguous films especially ones
that are kind of centered around
paranoia like is everybody out to get me
you know am i just losing my mind like
every single little thing that somebody
does every little piece of their
behavior is just kind of like shifty and
you can read it like in lots of multiple
ways and i really like that about it i
mean it had this really unsettling
undertone of like claustrophobia
just like much like rosemary's baby
where you know the protagonist jane like
it seems like the whole world is like
closing in around her uh she can't
really trust anybody if she goes to
somebody and talks to them it ends up
like [ __ ] her over at least in her
perception so i really really like that
aspect of i really like movies that can
pull that off successfully which i think
this one does uh cinematography in this
one is also really lovely it's very
gloomy very strange very trippy very
grotesque i really like a lot of the
nightmare images they're very it's you
know it's weird like fisheye lenses and
[ __ ] like it feels like you're you've
been dosed or something like that so uh
you know it's not a traditional or by
the numbers type of giallo movie so
don't expect the usual hallmarks like i
said like the mass killer and
like the kind of police procedural
aspect because it doesn't really have
that but it's definitely unique although
you know like i said it's on the fringes
of giallo it's usually called a giallo
movie and it is but it's kind of like an
outlier i guess because it's not exactly
like a classic example of the genre that
said i wouldn't hesitate to recommend it
not only to people that are really into
jello movies like me but also to fans of
those sort of like 70s era satanic panic
uh you know cult movies like the ones
that came about uh after rosemary's baby
ones like that
if you like that kind of stuff and you
like stuff with like really surrealistic
or trippy visuals then you'll probably
dig this one as well so that will do it
for this flickers of fear continuing on
with giallo july we'll do another one
next time and i will see you on that one
bye